je crois que l'occasion de la prise de
parole du chef de l'état c'est le moment
de fixer un cap savoir où on va quand on
regarde le rapport du professeur pitt et
owen bien car on a eu à défaut
d'anticipation de préparation de gestion
maintenant il faut une prise de parole
qui soit pas multiples comme parfois
nous l'avons qu'ils soient claires en
mettant en prioritaires des français au
travail à des français qu'ils soient
pour les enfants à l'école
et puis à tout prix éviter la cessation
des soins non qu'ovide on en parle peu
mais c'est essentiel nous avons eu un
certain nombre de mortalité qui ont été
liés par ces non prise en charge de
morbidité et où nous voyons bien que
nous sommes dans une crise d'autorité
on le voit dans la dimension vis-à-vis
des policiers il a vidé porteurs de
l'autorité on attend du chef de l'état
qu'il incarne cette clarté qui fixe un
cap qui nous propose une stratégie et
une méthode
vous avez l'impression vous parlez de
parole claire qu'elle ne l'a pas été
c'est à dire libre regarder depuis le
début de la semaine elle a été multiples
parfois dans tous les sens je pense que
ce soir c'est l'occasion de fixer le cap
il nous sommes capables de dépasser ja
lire tous les clivages dans une
démocratie c'est l'intérêt du pays
l'intérêt du pays c'est de protéger les
français et les français s'est en même
temps de protéger notre économie déjà
malmené et je crois que c'est l'occasion
d'une réaction citoyenne orange une
pensée pour ces policiers blessés pour
ces policiers atteints dans leur chair
condat une vraie crise de l'autorité on
peut pas y répondre par quelques tweets
ou quelques déplacements
vous pensez à qui quand vous dites oui
des déplacements france au ministre de
l'intérieur où je pense même au au
premier ministre pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut là aussi une stratégie
cette stratégie doit être définie comme
une stratégie comme nous avons défini en
2010 est la stratégie de défense il faut
au travers du livre blanc avoir cette
revue stratégique se fixer des objectifs
et qui porte sur quoi sur la
rétablissement de l'ordre républicain
sur le rétablissement de l'état de droit
c'est indispensable dans une démocratie
est derrière
une loi de programmation qui font un
continuum de sécurité qui part des
maires des polices municipales qui part
police et gendarmes va jusqu'à la
justice et l'exécution de justice
et puis il ya un couple est essentielle
pour la crise sanitaire pour la sécurité
c'est le couple préfet maire je crois
que c'est autour de ça que nous devons
rétablir là aussi on attend qu'un cadre
soit fixée je ne suis pas certain que
depuis trois ans et demi on est
réellement défini ce cap c'est
l'occasion peut-être ce soir aussi pour
le président de la république de le re
de le définir clairement